[Musik]
und jetzt das heute schon
guten abend die lage in der ukraine
bleibt heute weitgehend unverändert also
unverändert schrecklich zum allgemeinen
kriegsgeschehen kommen wir gleich noch
blicken aber zuerst nach bis nach
lemberg die stadt steht in besonderer
weise für die jüdische geschichte der
ukraine sie war eine der hochburgen
jüdischer kultur und jüdischer
intelligenz jahr vor den deutschen im
zweiten weltkrieg verfolgt und
weitgehend vernichtet von denen die
überlebten flüchteten später viele vom
stalinismus jetzt müssen dort
holocaust-überlebende wieder angst vor
krieg und vertreibung haben dara
hassanzadeh berichtet aus lemberg
die jüdische gemeinde in lemberg sie
lebt wohl an keinem ort wie putins
behauptung die ukraine von nazis zu
befreien absurder als hier in der
jüdischen synagoge
sie nehmen flüchtlinge aus der ganzen
ukraine auf die den bomben entkommen
sind
unter ihnen ist auch nina schiffer und
ihr ehemann sie überlebte den holocaust
weil ihre familie vor den nazis aus der
ukraine nach usbekistan flüchten konnte
nach dem zweiten weltkrieg kehrte sie in
ihre heimat im osten der ukraine zurück
dort lebte sie bis russische bomben
einschlugen
in 92 jahre alt und mein ehemann 93 und
wir mussten fliehen weil
weil putin ihre stadt micro bombardierte
später bat sie uns das interview
fortzusetzen
diese menschen sind absolute dummköpfe
vergleichbar mit der hitlerjugend und
anderen die in gleicher weise einer
gehirnwäsche unterzogen wurden
es ist eine schande dass die intelligenz
ja die gebildeten menschen russland
verlassen haben und dass es keinen
anführer gibt der dieses regime
niederschlagen kann
die
labore nach und ihr mann werden in einem
hotel untergebracht
die anderen flüchtlinge in den
büroräumen einer it-firma der jüdischer
eigentümer hat sie zur verfügung
gestellt die mitarbeiter sind im
home-office die flüchtlinge haben eine
bleibe
dieses jahr so hat die jüdische gemeinde
entschieden feiern sie im
flüchtlingsheim das purimfest ein
problem wird die errettung des jüdischen
volkes gefeiert damals aus der bedrohung
durch die perser
[Applaus]
nun droht ihm mit propaganda und mit
militärische eskalation muss man
verkündete heute es habe erstmals eine
seiner neuartigen hyperschall raketen
eingesetzt was angst einflößend klingt
und auch genauso wirken soll vor allem
ist es ein signal richtung nato solche
raketen haben lange reichweiten und
lassen sich kaum abfangen
angesichts all dessen was ich hier
gerade auf erden abspielt wird es umso
spezieller das hoch über unseren köpfen
auf der raumstation iss russen
amerikaner und europäer nach wie vor
friedlich zusammenarbeiten
heute gab es drei russische
neuankömmlinge in auffälligem outfit da
wird beginnt petra otto ihren bericht
so ein herzlicher empfang oben im all
als die russischen kosmonauten die
internationale raumstation iss ein
schreiben in ihren auffälligen
raumanzügen in gelb und in blau den
farben der ukraine zufall oder statement
ebenfalls aus großer höhe heute ein
russischer angriff mit einer hyperschall
rakete kind schaller übersetzt durch ist
laut putin unbesiegbar denn die
luftabwehrsysteme die könnten ihr nichts
anhaben eine neue stufe der eskalation
rakete mit hyperschall technik zerstörte
ein unterirdisches waffenlager und ein
munitionsdepot der ukrainischen truppen
nahe der ortschaft eliane team der jagd
in ein kleines dorf liegt 100 km vom
nato mitglied rumänien entfernt
die bomben egal aus welcher rakete sie
treffen nicht nur waffenlager jeden tag
fordert der krieg auch zivile opfer
112 kinder meldet die ukrainische
generalstaatsanwaltschaft
sei ein schulungs leben gekommen diese
familie hat ihren zweijährigen sohn
verloren leid und verzweiflung jeden tag
nun scheinen allerdings die flucht
korridore besser zu funktionieren
diese menschen haben es nach abriss ja
geschafft sicher ist es auch hier nicht
aber endlich raus aus mario puls
mario pohl existiert nicht mehr wir
saßen im keller 10 trage und kam nicht
raus hatten wäre wasser noch strom
und der präsident er ruft laut nach
friedensverhandlungen ja heute schon ich
möchte dass alle mich hören besonders in
moskau es ist zeit für ein treffen zeit
zu reden
dreieinhalb wochen krieg der frühling
kommt auch in kiew trotz invasion darum
legen sie tulpen auf dem sophien platz
aus unzählige in der form ihres landes
wattens gegen die angst
[Musik]
welchen preis sind die deutschen bereit
zu zahlen um putin zu bekämpfen bei den
deutschen autofahrern hat die
bundesregierung der offenkundig zweifel
zumindest die fdp ihren finanzminister
ja als quasi erste tricks folgen
maßnahme tank rabatte einführen will
tatsache ist dass die benzinpreise seit
kriegsausbruch auf rekordverdächtige
höhen geklettert sind und dort verharren
obwohl der hohe ölpreis zuletzt wieder
gesunken ist thaddäus parade berichtet
es ist die suche nach ein paar cent
ersparnis für den liter sprit die dieser
freien düsseldorfer tankstelle zur zeit
regen betrieb beschert doch selbst hier
rattern die euros an der zapfsäule nur
so durch spritpreis genervte autofahrer
fühlen sich geschafft wer ist schuld
ist nicht zu verschweigen
ich frage mich warum ist der preis
überhaupt so hoch
startschuss für die preisrallye war der
beginn des ukraine kriegs ein fass rohöl
der sorte brent kletterte auf weit über
100 dollar jetzt fällt die kurve wieder
trotzdem bleiben die spritpreise auf
hohem niveau warum das bleibt
betriebsgeheimnis der mineralölkonzerne
wir kennen den anteil den staatlichen
steuern und abgaben ausmachen den
anderen teil also etwa die hälfte des
spritpreises kennen wir nicht wir wissen
nicht wie hoch die produktionskosten
sind wir sind wissen nicht wie hoch
lieferkosten sind und letztendlich auch
nicht wie hoch die masche ist der
branchenverband energy fuels betont
jedoch die hohen preise sind
krisenbedingt zitat die kraftstoffpreise
sind infolge des ukraine kriegs stark
gestiegen dies gilt nicht nur für
deutschland sondern europa und weltweit
kritiker bestreiten dass weder angebot
noch nachfrage hätten sich mit
kriegsbeginn schlagartig geändert fakt
ist rohölpreis und spritpreis haben sich
entkoppelt und die preisentwicklung der
letzten wochen zeigt die gewinnmargen
beim sprit verkauf seit kriegsbeginn
legen deutlich zu
profitieren würden hauptsächlich
mineralölkonzerne sagt
wirtschaftsprofessorin monika schnitzer
von einem tank rabatt also einem
staatlichen zuschuss auf die hohen
spritpreise wegen der
bundesfinanzminister vorschlägt hält sie
nichts
es ist auch nicht zielgenau nicht
zielgenau weil in dem fall auch die
mineralölkonzerne wieder mächtig
profitieren würden unsere abschätzung
ist auf grundlage unserer frühere
studien um die 40 prozent denn die
würden einfach ihre preise natürlich ein
stück weit erhöhen das bundeskartellamt
soll die hohen spritpreise nun unter die
lupe nehmen wünscht sich dazu aber
konkretere daten
wir haben in anderen bereichen immer
wieder gefordert dass wir bessere daten
bekommen zum beispiel die frage zu
welchem preis welche menge an der
zapfsäule verkauft worden ist das wäre
noch exakter noch transparenter doch
diese daten halten mineralölkonzerne und
raffinerien bislang unter verschluss ob
und wie die autofahrer entlastet werden
ist noch nicht entschieden in berlin
soll nun eine kommission der ampel
fraktionen die vorstellungen von spd
grünen und fdp zu einem
würdest das einer gas das andere aus
deutscher sicht noch weit größeren
problem noch sei die gasversorgung für
den kommenden winter nicht ausreichend
gesichert sagt bundeswirtschaftsminister
habe ich rund 55 prozent bezogen wir
bislang aus russland da müssen jetzt
schnell alternativen her nachdem harbeck
auf einkaufstour schon in den usa und
norwegen war ist er heute nach katar
gereist danach geht es weiter in die
vereinigten arabischen emirate die
golfstaaten scheichs sind auch nicht
gerade das was man unbedenkliche
geschäftspartner nennt aber in der not
offenbar das kleinere übel von katar
erhofft sich habe ich vor allem
zusätzliche flüssiggas lieferungen
karl hinterleitner begleitet den
minister auf seiner reise kallwass was
hören sie wie verlaufen die gespräche
bisher
die bisherigen treffen seine
atmosphärisch gut verlaufen hieß es und
das spielt durchaus eine große rolle
nicht zuletzt betätigt sich minister
habig bei dieser reise als türöffner für
die deutsche wirtschaft denn am ende
kauft ja nicht der staat das gas so dass
tun deutsche unternehmen die wollen das
auch es ist eine hochrangige
wirtschaftsdelegation hier dabei das
who's who der deutschen energiebranche
die stehen in den startlöchern um katar
als energielieferanten zu gewinnen
allerdings ist das verhältnis zwischen
deutschland und katar sagen wir
reserviert vor allem von seiten der
kataris die die kritik an ihrem land
stichwort fußball wm noch im kopf haben
und hier verhalten sind das gilt es zu
verbessern wieder vertrauen zu schaffen
und ein zweck der reise vom minister
herbig ist auch das umfeld wieder so zu
gestalten dass geschäfte möglich sind
energie geschäfte die deutschland
dringend braucht dankeschön nach katar
nachrichten geht's am anfang auch noch
mal um energiefragen hans auch belgien
will unabhängiger von fossilen
brennstoffen werden die regierung hat
angekündigt die erneuerbaren energien
auszubauen und auch den atomausstieg zu
verschieben zwei der sieben reaktoren
des landes soll nicht wie geplant
2025 vom netz gehen sondern erst zehn
jahre später nordrhein westfalen das
seit langem störanfälligen reaktoren im
nachbarland kritisiert forderte eine
grenzüberschreitende
umweltverträglichkeitsprüfung
und strenge maßstäbe bei der
sicherheitsüberprüfung
zur corona situation und da zunächst
nach österreich
dort wird zwei wochen nach der
weitgehenden aufhebung der kroner
maßnahmen eine wieder eingeführt
angesichts stark steigender
infektionszahlen soll ab mitte kommender
woche wieder eine pflicht zum tragen von
fft zwei masken in öffentlichen
innenräumen gelten
zu den crooner infektionszahlen in
deutschland das robert koch institut
meldet
260.000
239 neue fälle in den 24 stunden
23.000 153 mehr als vor einer woche
außerdem kamen 2 121 todesfälle hinzu
die sieben tage incidents liegt jetzt
bei
bundespräsident steinmeier hat für drei
tage seinen amtssitz verlegt von berlin
nach altenburg in thüringen
der auftrag zu einer reise quer durchs
land mit dem titel ortszeiten auf seinen
stopps will steinmeier verstärkt den
direkten austausch mit menschen suchen
wie hier beim frühstück mit engagierten
bürgerinnen und bürgern
mehr als 200.000 geflüchtete aus der
ukraine sind bislang in deutschland
angekommen es ist wenig im vergleich zu
dem was die polen aktuell stemmen aber
auch um die hier ankommenden muss sich
gekümmert werden zumal das wohl erst der
anfang ist und schon jetzt zeigen sich
die behörden überfordert in berlin etwa
ist es geradezu möglich sich als
flüchtling zu registrieren um etwa im
notfall krankenversichert zu sein aber
wenn schon berliner nur schwerlich
termine auf ämtern bekommen wie soll das
dann erst ukraine an gelingen ein großer
teil der hilfsarbeit wird von
freiwilligen geleistet die überall in
deutschland anpacken ankommende begrüßen
betreuen unterbringen beispiel hamburg
von dort berichtet sven ricke
dieses private video zeigt was
freiwillige helfer inzwischen
organisieren ein bus mit 17 ukrainischen
familien abgeholt in moldawien
angekommen nördlich von hamburg die
gastfamilien warten schon jennifer syme
hat den transport organisiert in den
vergangenen zwei wochen hat sie ein
netzwerk mit mehr als 1500 freiwilligen
aufgebaut ja von ganz klein von
einzelnen personen plötzlich ganz riesig
geworden und ich man darf nicht
vergessen ich bin auch eine privatperson
das ist keine firma und wir versuchen
jetzt immer nach und nach dass der ort
dass die behörde und die freiwilligen
von ort zu ort zusammenarbeiten
es sind solche bilder die immer mehr
freiwillige auf den plan rufen eine
hoffnungslos überforderte
migrationsbehörde menschen die vier tage
und nächte bei minusgraden ausharren um
dran zu kommen der druck auf hamburgs
innenbehörde war groß seit zwei tagen
sind nun online terminen buchbar auf
deutsch wieder sind es freiwillige
helfer die mit privaten laptops
einspringen
aber was ich gemerkt habe ist das ist
auch total wichtig ist dass wir einfach
machen und drei anlaufstellen gibt es in
hamburg für die menschen aus der ukraine
in der zentralen erste aufnahme gab es
am anfang keine kleidung kein essen
keine windeln claudia kraemer hat am
ersten tag eine online gruppe ins leben
gerufen und einen tisch vor die tür
gestellt zwischen sind sie hier in
schichten eingeteilt und stehen zwölf
stunden am tag vor der städtischen
einrichtung ich glaube schon dass wir
eine große unterstützung sind auch für
die stadt wir bieten ja jetzt
mittlerweile auch viel
luxus artikel an so will ich mal sagen
von hygiene bis baby wir haben ein
bisschen babykleidung für die
neugeborenen kinderwagen also wirklich
das ist ja schon wirklich mehr als
erstversorgung würde ich sagen jennifer
syme plant seit zwei tagen den nächsten
bus transport direkt aus dem
ukrainischen grenzgebiet morgen kommen
durch sie vermittelt weitere 70 schutz
suchende menschen in der nähe von
hamburg an die gastfamilien hat sie
inzwischen gefunden wieder ganz ohne
eine staatliche stelle
in diesem ganzen kriegsgeschehen lohnt
es sich nicht nur in die ukraine zu
blicken in der region gibt es noch
andere potenzielle ziele die putin
ansteuern könnte und so ist jetzt wieder
die zeit der landkarten in der man sich
mit weltgegenden befasst die für viele
von uns er blinde flecken sind beispiel
moldawien beziehungsweise förmlich
republik moldau barbara lueg es dort für
uns nach kutsche riege heißt ein dorf an
der grenze zu transnistrien
das ist die von moldau abtrünnigen
regionen die von russischen soldaten
gehalten wird während sich moldau
richtung eu wendet ist transnistrien
vergleichbar mit den ostukrainischen
separatisten gebieten eine ähnliche
gemenge lage also wie in der ukraine
wir sind auf dem weg nach coach erie im
osten moldawiens nur mit der fähre
erreichen wir dieses abgeschiedenen dorf
das geduckt zwischen den welten kauert
seit 30 jahren ist coach jerry umzingelt
von transnistrien der pro-russischen
separatisten republik von der tatjana
nur noch genervt ist
ich weiß nicht warum die russen hier
sind warum sie immer noch hier sind
vielleicht gibt einen geheimplan ich
weiß es nicht
vor 30 jahren erklärt sich transnistrien
nach einem blutigen krieg mit moldawien
unabhängig von niemandem anerkannt aber
von moskau finanziert russische soldaten
bewachen seither den landstrich und ein
riesiges waffenarsenal
was die menschen im moldawischen cuturi
umtreibt ist so gespalten so
konfliktreich wie die große weltpolitik
ludmilla und ihr mann sitzen in der
mittagssonne auf der bank aber ludmilla
sagt ich sitze auf einem pulverfass
chemie wolfen die russen können
jederzeit sagen wir machen es hier wie
in der ukraine
ich habe angst dass russland uns alle
auch zerstört
ein paar straßen weiter verläuft die
grenze zu transnistrien bewacht von
russischen soldaten denen wir nicht
nachkommen dürfen im rathaus unter
moldawischer flagge meidet
gemeindesekretär ivan ihren anblick
ohnehin seit jahrzehnten
warum ist russland denn so groß geworden
weil es andere immer annektiert wurde es
liegt in ihrem blut anderen land
wegzunehmen so ist es doch seit
jahrhunderten
es ist markttag in coaching zwei stände
drei marktfrauen ganz andere stimmen wir
lernen natascha kennen die von hier aus
alles miterlebt hat den krieg den
zerfall der sowjetunion das streben
moldawiens richtung westen dass sie
nicht gutheißen kann
die russen waren doch in ordnung jeder
hatte einen job die renten waren
ordentlich jetzt haben wir nichts mehr
publikum
alte sehnsüchte neue ordnungen cuturi
zerrüttet im langen schatten der
russischen übermacht viktor einer der
ältesten hier hat akzeptiert dass sich
die welt weiter dreht stück seine
haltung aber nicht mehr um gute ihn
unterstütze ich nicht so 100 prozent wer
braucht all dieses blut aber was sollen
wir denn machen die nato kommt doch auch
immer näher an russische grenzen
im zentrum coach er ist ein denkmal die
gefallenen helden des dorfes die im
kampf gegen die separatisten fielen die
bewohner coach iris trauern gemeinsam um
sie nur an russland scheiden sich die
geister
und jetzt nochmals mit den lottozahlen
dieses samstags sie lauten wie immer
ohne gewähr
15 17 26
28 41 superzahl 5 und weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf de und zdf text auf seite 55 6 die
wetteraussichten für morgen noch über
den westen ziehen wolken aus denen es
auch mal einen kurzen schauer geben kann
sonst bleibt es trocken und die sonne
scheint bei einem lebhaften südostwind
werden 9 bis 18 grad erreicht in den
nächsten tagen scheint dann überall die
sonne und es wird wärmer ab am mittwoch
gibt es zwölf bis 20 grad
das war es an uns weitergeht vielleicht
mit der thriller-serie der überfall und
gegen 0.25 gibt es dann die nächste
heute express und uns morgen wieder auf
wiedersehen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]